halo infinite's multiplayer beta kind of
throws you into the deep end without
much explanation of its new weapons
equipment or multiplayer modes there's a
lot that's not immediately apparent when
you start the game if you fire up
multiplayer right on the spot you'll
likely find yourself pretty confused
we've been playing a lot of halo
infinite over the last few days and have
come across all kinds of useful
information about how the game works
these tips will help you hit the ring
world running give you a few key
strategies for its big modes and help
you become a more effective spartan
teammate
it's tempting to jump right into
multiplayer but before you get going on
halo infinite you should scroll down the
main menu list to the item marked
academy this is where you'll learn the
ins and outs of halo infinite which
includes a quick tutorial you've got
this
it's not gonna be easy
but i believe in you
if you're a halo veteran most of the
tutorial will cover stuff you already
know but it does highlight a few tidbits
about some of the new gear in the game
and it gives you a quick bot fight to
try some stuff out more useful for most
players will be the weapon drills option
which takes you to a shooting range
where you can try out every single one
of infinite's guns in my opinion this is
essential to drastically reducing your
learning curve in the game it'll let you
try each gun including the new ones and
see how it works the range at which it
will be effective how fast it can kill
enemies and if it sports an alternate
fire mode getting a feel for every gun
before you head into multiplayer matches
makes it much easier to make decisions
on the battlefield about which weapon
you want to take into any given
situation
[Music]
you'll usually start a match with the
ma40ar
and the sidekick pistol but as soon as
you begin you can quickly find new guns
to swap these out
primarily these weapons are found
attached to racks on walls and you can
just pluck them from there guns don't
appear immediately on racks once they've
been grabbed though they'll take a while
to respawn and you can tell how long you
have to wait by checking the blue meter
at the top of the rack when you approach
it stronger guns halo infinite's power
weapons will spawn at specific places
scattered around the map you'll usually
see these marked with yellow icons
that'll tell you when the next one is
due and you want to work to nab these
guns as often as possible a rocket
launcher or gravity hammer in the right
hands at the right time can swing a
match in your favor or against you so
make it a priority to control them halo
infinite has four kinds of grenades and
in most matches you can carry four
grenades at a time two of one type and
two of another you can switch between
your carried grenade types by hitting
left on the d-pad on controller or the n
key on keyboard make a mental note of
where each type of grenade appears on
the map so you can snag them when you
need them you always want as many
grenades as you can carry as grenades
are a great way to either open a fight
with an enemy or finish it
the four types of grenades means that
each has different use cases so try to
grab the one you need for what you
expect to face
frag grenades the default are solid
all-around explosives that are good at
either knocking out an enemy shield or
finishing off a weakened enemy but
you'll often find that players survive
them fairly easily so huck these with
abandon while you're shooting plasma
grenades are blue and have smaller
explosions but they're sticky land one
on a player and it's a guaranteed kill
and they're effective for bringing down
vehicles dynamo grenades bounce around
on the ground dealing electrical damage
to the area around them over time which
makes them great for closing off or
clearing a specific area players who
stand near them for a prolonged period
will also be killed by them finally
spike grenades are designed for damaging
infantry in close interior spaces
they do less damage than frags but they
will stick to walls and shoot out spikes
that ricochet around to hit opponents
again and again in addition to guns and
grenades you'll also find deployable
equipment scattered around the
battlefield
these include a grapple hook deployable
cover a recon sensor that highlights
enemies a thruster that gives you a
short range dash and a repulsor that can
bounce things away from you they're
similar to the armor abilities in past
halo games and each has very specific
use cases the repulsor for instance can
stop vehicles cold when they'd normally
run you over or send enemies back when
they get too close
the deployable cover gives you a shield
you can shoot through but that will
briefly stop incoming bullets and the
dash lets you quickly move in any
direction
you should give all the equipment a try
and make sure you always have something
equipped each equipment piece has
limited numbers of uses but in the right
circumstances they can save your life
there are also two kinds of equipment
that rank in the same tier as power
weapons the active camo and the
overshield these are highlighted like
power weapons on your hud and usually
spawn in the center of the map you want
to grab these as soon as they're
available just like power weapons
because they give a big advantage the
overshield doubles your shield capacity
to make you much harder to kill although
it won't recharge like your normal
shield and the active camo renders you
all but invisible for a brief period
grab these or at the very least keep
them out of the hands of the other team
a little known feature in halo
infinite's multiplayer is the ai scan
option
hit the button for it either z on
keyboard or down d-pad on controller and
you'll send out a scanning pulse around
you that can help you identify things on
the map the ai scan will highlight
points of interest on your hud like
weapon racks and empty vehicles if
you're desperate for a gun but don't
know where to find one use your scanner
to help point you toward what you need
it won't show you where players are use
the threat sensor equipment for that but
it will highlight everything else that's
interactable including launch pads
like most current team-based
first-person shooters halo infinite
sports a ping system called mark in the
control menu that lets you highlight
locations or enemies on your teammate's
hud enemy there the system isn't as
robust as in say apex legends but it is
a useful nonverbal way to show your
allies where the action is where they
can find weapons or vehicles you don't
need or where opposing players are
congregating marking targets can be very
helpful to your team so spread the intel
around mark defaults to x on the
keyboard and up d-pad on controller
like power weapons vehicles are
essential to winning a lot of matches in
halo infinite they give you a ton of
extra mobility and oftentimes firepower
you can use the vehicles themselves as
weapons or to get out of a tight spot
and their mounted guns generally cut
through spartans without much trouble
don't leave vehicles to rust on the
field or worse to get snagged by the
other team use them to your advantage
even if you're not an especially
effective killer while driving or riding
any vehicle can help you quickly cross
the battlefield draw enemy attention and
create a little chaos you can even take
them into launch pads and send them
flying a warthog mongoose or ghost
harassing a group of spartans means your
allies on foot have a better chance of
killing them while they're looking at
you just be sure not to run over your
teammates
conversely if the enemy is using a
vehicle against you especially airborne
ones you're going to want to deal with
them post haste a well-piloted banshee
or wasp can wallop a team on the ground
that isn't looking up to handle it most
standard small arms will do little
damage to most vehicles although you can
usually target their pilots or gunners
but middle tier and power weapons are
highly effective in bringing them down
two of the best guns for dealing with
vehicles quickly are the
electricity-based ones the disrupter
pistol and shock rifle a few shots from
the disruptor will disable a vehicle
including a banshee or a wasp sending it
falling out of the sky fully charged
shock rifle shots can do the same if
you're being hassled by vehicles seek
out the lightning weapons
the enemy carrier ammo reserves to
pleading
but don't forget that the hydra skewer
sentinel beam rocket launcher sniper
rifle and plasma grenade are all
effective weapons as well if a vehicle
is giving you a hard time shoot at it
because every little bit of damage helps
you can also blow off the tires of
ground vehicles or the wings of aerial
vehicles to deal them extra damage if
you saw the halo infinite multiplayer
announcement trailer you know how useful
the grapple shot equipment can be it
gives you a grappling hook you can shoot
at just about anything and if you find
one you should use it the grapple can be
used to zip you up to high locations
that are great for sniping and halo
infinite is much more vertical than is
obvious once you start trying to do this
you can also use it to snag weapons or
items from the ground around you
allowing you to grab something you need
without leaving cover even better though
you can use the grapple against
opponents snag another sniper with the
gravel and you'll be rocketed toward
them with your character automatically
hitting them with a melee when you
arrive so don't try to time it yourself
you can also grapple vehicles and
automatically board them if they're
empty or automatically hijack them if
they're not use the grapple to get
yourself out of a bind or to quickly get
yourself into a fight it's not just for
climbing
halo infinite's radar works a little
differently than what you might see in
other shooters or in past games in halo
infinite you appear on the radar when
you're moving firing or sprinting and
you don't appear when you stop moving or
move while crouching being judicious
about revealing yourself is essential to
sneaking up on opponents and killing
them without being spotted so be careful
about when you run or when you choose to
engage with enemies you might also want
to play with headphones or your volume
turned up as you can usually hear
approaching footsteps when opponents
draw near in some cases in objective
games you'll also be highlighted on the
enemy's hud but you can take steps to
avoid that too while a flag in ctf or
seed in stockpile is highlighted on the
hud for players when it isn't being
carried if you pick up one of those
objectives it stops being highlighted
but you will be highlighted for all
opponents to see if you're holding an
objective and sprinting you can also be
revealed when you're shot while holding
an objective so bear that in mind as
well it's okay to toss an objective in
order to engage in a fight then pick it
up again after you've won if the
alternative means exposing yourself and
getting easily taken down the stockpile
multiplayer mode is likely throwing a
lot of players for a loop
your team needs one more power seed it's
a lot like capture the flag but there
are roughly 9 flags on the field at any
given moment and a given team needs to
return 5 of them to their base in order
to score a point instead of flags though
what you need to claim are power seeds
small battery-like objects that spawn in
the middle of the map and are marked on
your hud your goal in these matches is
to procure seeds while stopping the
opposing team from claiming any but when
you pick up a seed you're unable to
fight much like when you carry the
oddball or the flag the good news is
that you can throw seeds and it's an
effective strategy for several players
to group up grab seeds and huck them
toward their base over and over rather
than trying to carry them the whole way
this way you can keep moving the seeds
while still fighting anyone who comes
after you vehicles are also a good way
to get seeds back home you can't drive
while carrying one but you can hold one
as a passenger just like the flag and
with the razorback the gunless version
of the warthog you can actually install
two seeds on the back bumper with
players piling into the car carrying
seeds that means you can haul as many as
four back to a base with one vehicle in
total control games your team's goal is
to capture and hold three designated
spots on the map on big team maps your
team needs to capture all three
locations at the same time to score a
point so when you see your opponents
starting to snag that third zone you
might start to panic a little there's a
strategy to apply here though you can
stop the other team from scoring simply
by beginning to capture a zone yourself
points are only scored when one team
holds all three zones unopposed that
means that in these scenarios you
shouldn't necessarily scramble for the
zone the other team is about to capture
but rather one of the two they already
have if the other team is about to score
if they capture point c you can expect
that most of their team is already on it
trying to capture it that might mean
that point a or point b are relatively
or completely unguarded step onto either
of these spots without an opponent to
stop you and you'll begin the capture
sequence preventing them from scoring a
point just be wary that the other team
can also use this trick against you so
it's a good idea to leave members of
your team on every point even after you
capture it so they can mount a defense
one infuriating oversight in halo
infinite is that you seemingly have no
ability to mute individual teammates in
the game's team chat if someone leaves
their mic on or if a chatty group joins
your quick play match you might find
yourself cringing as you're forced to
listen to whatever they have to say or
just as frequently whatever's happening
in the background of the room they're
playing in you can mute individual
players but it's a bit counterintuitive
finding the place to do so pull up the
social menu either by hitting start on
controller or escape on keyboard and
find the roster of players in your match
from there click their profiles and the
opportunity to mute them one by one will
be available you can also shut down team
chat wholesale in the settings menu once
you're there scroll to the bottom of the
audio menu you can toggle off voice chat
and text chat in game lobbies and in
matches on this screen although it
doesn't seem to be fully effective
ratcheting down the incoming voice chat
volume slider to zero however will make
it so you never have to hear anyone in a
match ever again for more halo infinite
coverage be sure to like this video and
subscribe to the gamespot channel and
check out gamespot.com for everything
halo infinite
killing spree